there's Eric Carlson the big deal in the off
season to acquire him from San Jose two the
older teams in the NHL here's Rasmus sandine nice
pit tap to Tom Wilson Wilson R go Tom Wilson 55
seconds in gets his 11th of the year with the
twisted rer and the capitals score the first
goal of the game and it's the big Power Forward
Tom Wilson this comes by way of a great clean
breakout unreal breakdown the pass by R sand
to Tom Wilson who was inches away from getting
his stick on that R shot from Wilson man that
was just a perfectly placed bomb here's gray
see if he can answer his shot save by keer and
Alex leetom gets the rebound that be something
to keep an eye on with that ovest line the
length of shifts don't have that extended
endurance that they had in years past so quicker
shenin got save by jar he'll chip it in oetkin
now on the four check comes Edmonson he fires
towards and that's sa by jar again the rebound
was there oetkin poked at it here comes gensel
in Jake gensel stot and wide looking to kick that
corner like Tom Wilson did he just missed Here
Comes Valenstein sck work by deflect into the
net Beck malinin gets his fourth of the
year he was trying to put the puck in
front of the net Ryan Graves penguin Defender
deflected into his own cage and own goal to
the Delight of these catm here in Pittsburgh
and this comes by way of the shot by gel and
you miss wide and this cues the transition
for the Washington Capitals and Malin takes
this strong and makes an attempt to get that
back towards that props to their skills coach
Kenny mccut who we spoke to this morning
C who said keep an eye on Valenstein and
he certainly comes through here with a goal
in the capitals come out with it looking to
set it up and get a chance stro fakes the shot
barar in front again looking for a deflection
perhaps stick or skate Capital still have
another good shift for Washington farari
score and once again it's a defenseman
the team who had struggled all year to
get help from their blue line hasn't received
very much help but Alison doovic will come on
great in zone offense here control the boards
control the game look at farari he started up
high takes it back regains possession and
throws this one toward the net taking full
advantage of the screen here Celly absolutely
it's a miscommunication by Pittsburgh there you
can see a CH comes up off the timeout almost
a chance for Raquel But Here Come the caps
again protus McMichael open in front is sand
redirection big save by the doovic right off
the bat right off the bat indeed glovs side
pad that big one pad courtesy and N delovic
who makes this stop in tight nice save here
Kelly was instrumental on the first goal and
sandine almost got his first of the year right
there and here comes oetkin now in the middle
to kazet on he goes to his office short Side
High rot a good one but there's adulov aari in
front Carter in front good shift here from this
fourth line aari open big save by ker three ler
front Carter looking for number 436 can't fish it
out as he looks to the rafting being physical of
c and ultimately generating some chances as well
yeah starts with a four checking control the puck
downar through some body some checks there and
you can see this puck just squeez through keer
Carter sees it but he can't get his stick on it
keer reaches back and covers it up you can watch
here Carter actually just States right over it
when it comes uh comes right behind keer weeks
keer does a good job of tracking over shoulder
see where his head position here whiffs out of
midair good thing would have been played with a
high stick and the Penguins go Rael shot blocked
nice play by sandine the B there's Crosby gets
the turnover goes to Rael back to Crosby to gel
back to Crosby bear has it knocked into the
boards by Crosby Peng are set up one timer
St Chad R this is a turnover you've got
to man that puck better if you're down
this a simple play to get that zone
exit now they're hamstrung they're
deep in their defensive zone for an
extended shift Crosby with the hit on
bear and this could very well be an offside
call so we'll wait for that decision but here
comes a long range shot because that's not the
best angle if it was hovering so here comes the
goal we assume it will be dis 344 of the first
period the play was deemed be offside therefore
we have no kicks it to his tape Ian Eller begin
the PK for the Penguins up top keep couple good
keeps right there that's close Carlson amstrong
H Carlson save by the delus onehanded just wide
from Wilson coasting around the offensive zone
trying to find that dead area to unleash that
Slap Shot back to the point sandine tap set up
now fake shot sandine he's got some confidence
in his game after that early there with there
toi to The Net score 830 for Alex oetkin makes
it 4 nothing Washington as my man EJ always says
watch this play here watch up top Alexander obesin
left of your screen he's playing the role
of John Carlson he's all the way up like a
defenseman c and a very simple and effective shot
as you pointed out Cali this shot from distance
Alexander o do it yeah he does and you know what
we saw in the first Power Play I thought maybe he
just got out of position on the ends up in the
back of your neet Crosby Joseph R shot saay by
keer Rebound in front crosy tries to fish it
out it comes to Carlson one kler Rael KN the
B the penguin h on the board with 4 seconds
to go Ricard ratel plus his third of the year
for the Penguins 37 seconds after Obie made it 4
nothing they had the disallowed goal previously
and they get back into the psycho game offensively
second effort third after back the same thing it's
a baway shot from distance some traffic this
Puck looked a little bit like a breaking ball
from the Pirates just up the street here and
it goes bar down no chance there Kelly AB new
to the net goes behind the net to the right
point where pus in cover L Tang's got room
R shot into the glove easy save half the arena
thought it went in cuz the net fluttered malan
hard gensel shot save by ke oh the rebound Swept
Away Carlson Ming here's gensel shot deflected
score Sydney Crosby It's a power play goal one
for Obie One for Sid it's his 21st goal of the
year and the capitals lead is now forwarded to
I'll get one of my own and this one reflects the
city of Pittsburgh all blue collar second effort
watch Sydney Crosby goes down on his in a squat
here in the middle of your screen there he is
gets underneath the D down a one one two three
efforts at this one t before he finally puts
it home I love what he does there he just makes
himself big he just wants that putt to head off
and and go in less than a minute into this affair
had five more goals since then we're up to six
42 Washington as we're down to 70 seconds to go
here in the second wisec front sa score Jake
Del's off the board and it's a onego game in
Pittsburgh denel has been red hot of late and
that's his 17th of the Year remaining here in
the second period and here come the pens wise
on the board chip get in Sydney Crosby F2 on
the four chest second effort third effort
hunger hunting pucks on that for check led
to this one by gel CI and I just love hear
look at crossby not only does he make that
hit but he turns around right away and he has the
awareness he knows where gel is in front of the
net y flipped his hand over he's trying to
win his back in to Letang or Carlson oh what
a great job byal he just whacks It Forward
probably a Faceoff stat loss but that's a win